alors quoi qu'en serait il pas plus
lever il y avait tout le côté d'or a
paralysé votre père risque de ne plus
pouvoir parler nous alimenter tout autre
[Musique]
je vais rien faire sans toi centaine
d'accords rien de toute façon c'est à
toi qui l'a demandé c'est un mauvais
père
oui cela m j'aurais adoré l'avoir comme
ami alors être lus comme une amie en
france c'est pas possible
plus confus gérer contact avec une
association celui-ci mais il faudrait
aller là-bas prévu ce sera vous habert
et programmes que même tous forte depuis
mompontet jusqu'alors très solide très
éclairant au plus près des fils suit
presse hockey entre nous a expliqué
qu'il pouvait plus changer d'avis quand
et si papa regarde dans les yeux tu sais
tellement lui et non au fond
beaucoup à chaud sur le peuple pour
épeler marche c'est pas mon anniversaire
au presque fait bouger de faire les
choses sous sol de la vie normale ou
presque n'a jamais dit et papa avec tout
ce qu'il a fait subir
qu'est ce que ça fait du bien on était
toutes frigo et je me sens vivante
tu te rends compte qu'on est en train
pour lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en pleurs
[Musique]
et si vous refusiez que se passerait-il